when i was a kid i used to watch the
academy awards every single year's
family so i never ever thought i would
win an academy award
just having a moment like this being
here at the oscars that is magical so
i'd say to my younger self all the
stories you have to tell try and tell me
because they're the best ones you know i
mean i started long time ago when i
started projecting max senate pictures
against the wall of my bedroom i've been
quest love for 30 years and if you could
tell the person that used to busk for
change on south street in philadelphia
where his life is headed
wow
well my daughter has grown up and she
saw me as her father always being busy
performing on stage at all these various
theaters and and she was trying to
understand what her father was doing but
i think finally now she's able to
witness this and come along in my
journey and come along on this wild ride
with me
hey
i'm so proud of you thanks thanks this
is cool right
how's it feeling neil
this feels nice yeah yeah yeah that's
how i describe it that is the joy of
living is experiencing
you know new surprising
aspects of life and that's
what this is
just believe in your dreams carry on do
it
make mistakes learn from your mistakes
and don't stop doing it
[Music]
when i came here to this country
i had an oscar that i borrowed that i
put in my office and i was really
looking at it every day and saying maybe
one day i'd be lucky to get one key
thing is to never give up yeah never
give up for your dreams
[Music]
you